[Music]
and Trump is dump Oh question mark dot
submitted by is this real-life President
Trump has been impeached a peach let's
talk about this right now I don't know
what a peach mitt means understanding
either I think this means how about that
I think I guess like well I'm trying
remember from like the Clinton thing
right yeah so I don't know if years old
but I think what I mean from I remember
from the Clinton right because he got
impeached and then he had to go to trial
so I'm not sure if like when somebody
gets in peace are they scared all do you
remember talked about for years the
posture so like it was a class in my
history class all this other [ __ ] and I
was addicted to watching late night
comedy back then like I watched every
[ __ ] thing i watch Letterman and Leno
and everything and Senator sarin live
and they all they talked about was that
yeah and there wasn't social media back
then so all we had was TV yes then as
well all that was you know Howard I
don't understand it it doesn't do
anything I read that it's like the third
president in history yes well it's not
even complete cuz he's got to go to the
Senate it's like what's you know what
exactly is an impeachment okay so what
impeachment is just it's just a
resolution stating that hey we think you
did something bad and that's that's all
it is and it's just and unless the
Senate approves it by a two-thirds
majority which means like okay that's a
lot a lot of votes
you really don't remove the president
from office which is why that's never
happened in history so the it's never
happened in history like Nixon resigned
like everyone thinks Nixon got impeached
it's like he didn't even get impeached
at all nobody there was no declaration
because he resigned because it was a
bipartisan thing like the Republicans
and Democrats were like yo you should
focus it that couldn't get impeached or
he resigned to Clinton got impeached but
he did not get removed by the Senate
they don't even come close they did not
make a good case at bucking all cuz
they're just like he's getting his dick
sucked well it was probably right and
and even though he I guess perjured
himself or whatever the [ __ ] they they
say on the right right he know
was like this is a reason why you should
overturn the results of a [ __ ]
election which is the whole controversy
right everyone's like you shouldn't
overturn the will the American people
who spoke through the electoral college
deserve system and said Bill Clinton
does our president by removing him
because you guys hate him and the right
was after him from the [ __ ] jump
which is crazy because if you look at
Bill Clinton now he's basically the same
as Trump like every [ __ ] policy every
[ __ ] thing he said all of the things
that Bill Clinton actually did are
almost identical to Trump so this whole
this whole thing is is pretty well okay
so so basically the House of
Representatives they impeached chomp on
the like yesterday which may be free
sauce to go to the trial for it to be
affected so it goes then goes from the
house to the Senate per the Constitution
and the Senate has to vote two-thirds to
remove the president but that's not
gonna happen at all so it's basically
just a [ __ ] big fear what is he
getting impeach like what's the big
crime he thought you say that he
obstructed Congress and that he worked
with Ukraine well that's that's what the
the case is about right is that and and
feel free to jump in anybody at any
point but yeah so so basically the idea
is that it's like I don't know what
glory has that Trump was on a call each
part right now is just like the group of
people that's talking about this we're
all like I'm missus fascinating to me
because I know nothing we're all
learning history like that he so he like
who Hearst the new Ukraine president to
dig up dirt on Hillary and that's the
whole thing uh no so politically asked
for the president of Ukraine to
investigate what Joe Biden and what what
the Biden's were doing in Ukraine like
so Joe Biden's son was making a [ __ ] ton
of money he has no experience in you in
gas at all he works at the Ukrainian gas
company called burries ma Holdings and
he is like he's making like 80k a month
on the ship he's Duncan checks left and
right yeah [ __ ] it's like hello like
that is corruption right because why is
Joe Biden's son working at this thing
and and Trump is saying hey investigate
this ship and a lot of sounds like a
good guy well we'll see cuz cuz I'm not
saying I'm not saying that I know what's
going on I'm saying that's what the
right says right so the right says that
well that's actually just what happened
right Joe Biden's son is working at
Purisima Holdings Joe Biden's son is
dunking checks Joe Biden's son does not
have experience with gas okay Joe
Biden's son says nobody there really had
much experience I was pretty tight at it
okay he's also a solid case he's also a
[ __ ] crate like he his record is nuts
the guy has been popped for heroin he
was with hookers and he they could smell
like plastic burning coming from like
one of the bottle service rooms and
they're like yo this guy's like smoking
crack in there getting the [ __ ] out of
here like Joe Biden's son is like trash
trash right seller some Epstein
information exactly brother thank you oh
my god this guy I love this man okay so
that's what I'm saying this whole thing
is political theater just the same way
that the Clinton impeachment was
political theater and if you guys are
like [ __ ] Steve he loves Trump or
whatever this is all the same [ __ ] that
Jimmy Dore says who is the [ __ ]
biggest liberal on the internet who I
[ __ ] love that I've met him he's
[ __ ] dope Jimmy Dore no
like he has he has the best and most
cogent arguments for all this stuff so
you should just definitely check him out
but the idea is that Congress is saying
that Trump told Ukraine to investigate
Joe Biden and and that's what's [ __ ]
up right that that's what the Democrats
are saying that there was a quid pro quo
which means like you do something and
I'll give you something back so if you
do this if you investigate to a Biden I
will give you the aid money that that
you that Ukraine kids from the United
States government's like billions at all
and so
Ukraine got the money and they did not
open an investigation on the Biden's
however
Joe Biden at one point you can watch
this there's a [ __ ] video of Joe
Biden saying hey there's a prosecutor in
Ukraine who is investigating verismo
Holdings and and and the gas company
that has some work done I got that guy
fired by by saying like and you can
google this [ __ ] you can watch this
video right now Joe Biden
is Lily nuts for saying this on camera
he's like yeah like they had this
prosecutor who's looking into all the
corruption over there and I had him
fired I said well we're guess what I got
the president's on my side you're not
gonna give you the money so we're gonna
give you the aid money so well [ __ ] you
guys
and that's the guys fired by this
afternoon and my plane takes off and
then the guy got fired go figure
and now that prosecutors saying yeah we
have the goods on the Biden's over there
and this is the same [ __ ] that half with
the Muller report what happened with the
Muller fort right Russian collision
that's all everyone never said this in
Russian collusion Trump colluded with
Russia all this [ __ ] right this is all
just a [ __ ] distraction okay what did
Robert Muller say he said I will not
charge President Trump because of the
office of legal counsels guidelines that
comes from the Justice Department that
says you cannot prop you cannot indict a
sitting president
I'm not going to prosecute Trump because
of this I will not indict him right
that's what he said at his opening
statement of the when when they had him
in front of that the house were others
okay what did Muller amend his statement
to say after lunch after lunch after the
[ __ ] media got the headline Robert
Miller says you cannot indict a sitting
president according to Office of Legal
Counsel Robert Moeller meant a statement
to say when I said that that's not
really what happened I actually told the
Justice Department I
I was not under the office of legal
counsels guidelines I there's no reason
why we would indict Trump that's what
Bob Weller amended his statement to say
but that gets [ __ ] buried you can
google it it's everywhere CNN berries at
MSNBC buries it
Fox News is the only [ __ ] place that
actually runs it because it works to
their side right so that's what's [ __ ]
up is that during the Bush years it was
all like everything's Pro Iraq war pro
war Pro Afghanistan war and the
Democrats are like [ __ ] these wars we
should look into the [ __ ] [ __ ] more as
we don't want Wars now all of a sudden
that [ __ ] switches sides just because of
who the president is and so everyone's
freaking the [ __ ] out right now going
like well Trump should be impeached
because
probably Russia and stuff but Robert
Moeller investigate Russia
he said we found nothing he said if
anything we maybe would have got him for
obstruction of justice but then he says
you know what they actually wouldn't
even dated him for it so that's what
happened right here right they got this
guy named ambassador song 'land who was
the US ambassador for the United Nations
and he said hey when when it comes to
trump and Ukraine there was a quid pro
quo that's what he says in his opening
statement same [ __ ] [ __ ] as Muller
right same game plan right
so Soglin says we found that we believe
that the the Prezi knighted States who I
talked to personally on the phone he had
a quid pro quo with Ukraine and that is
[ __ ] up and he should be removed from
he should be dealt with or whatever
[ __ ] centered whatever well guess
what he amended his statement same thing
as Bob Muller look all this [ __ ] up
[ __ ] the [ __ ] out of me
what did he amend his statement to say
he said well okay actually when I talked
to Trump on the phone he told me don't
there's no quid pro quo with Ukraine
tell the president of Ukraine to do the
right thing that's what he said so
that's why everyone's like wait this is
a [ __ ] game that the Democrats are
playing the same way the Republicans
played the same game in nineteen five
right now is the is Trump still
president
yes president he's not going anywhere
that's what's and he can still run for
reelection a lot of people think he
can't even run for reelection yes he can
and if anything the Democrats just
handed him to so much firepower he could
say thick news now and there's a lot of
[ __ ] a bin that's fake in the news that
he can use as ammunition
so how [ __ ] stupid are these people
that's what I can't believe is that the
end result is the same every time the
Democrats David they [ __ ] dust up a
storm oh we got Trump this time he's
[ __ ] every time
Trump beats them says fake news they
lose then Democrats wake up in the
morning and they go wait he's still
president he's not going down what the
[ __ ] happened when they get dissolution
where they try and pitch the vice
president you know oh so right so that's
the whole thing it's like we're gonna
make do you can there's a lot of like
Trump's stuff
he does in terms of like policy gets
overshadowed because of his antics but
if he is somebody would just be like hey
shut the [ __ ] up right doesn't like just
do what you're doing and then take it
down here people would be less than fine
to hate him no doubt no doubt but that's
what that's this game right so like so I
think what's happening and I am very
skeptical of Trump because of Saudi
Arabia he is the biggest [ __ ]
[ __ ] for Saudi Arabia not Russia
like all this [ __ ] about Russia was a
[ __ ] SIOP by our intelligence
community who wanted to cover for the
one thing that nobody [ __ ] talks
about anymore which is how the Democrat
Party [ __ ] Bernie Sanders they [ __ ]
him over how did I [ __ ] him over so they
changed the rules during the last
election they basically set the table up
so that Hillary could get the nomination
and they admitted that [ __ ] Donna
Brazile the former head of the DNC she
admitted that [ __ ] and all heezy they
have tons of emails about the [ __ ] and
all this got exposed by somebody who
hacked the DNC okay and all that got
turned into if you even talk about that
you're talking about Russian propaganda
because Russia hacked the DNC that's
what everyone says instead of saying hey
isn't that [ __ ] up that they [ __ ]
Bernie Sanders over and all those
Sanders voters like people my friends
like a lot of people I know who love
Bernie Sanders and what he was about
they're all like wait why the [ __ ] is
Bernie Sanders not even sticking up for
the fact that he got [ __ ] over and
it's because if you even talked about
how the DNC got hacked and like they
found all these emails confirming that
they were [ __ ] over Bernie Sanders
people say you're using Russian
propaganda right now you should shut the
[ __ ] up that's what happens to people
right and that's what happened to Tulsi
Gabbard who is one of my favorite people
Tulsi Gabbard who's running for the
Democratic nomination right now because
she's doing very poorly in polls because
the Clintons trashed her they said she's
a Russian asset all this [ __ ] she's
basically saying like hey I don't think
that people who don't want to be at war
in Syria and Afghanistan and Iraq are
Russian apologists or even Russian
assets
which is what the clintons called her I
think that they're just anti-war which
is how he used to be isn't that crazy
how we used to be anti-war as Democrats
and that was the biggest [ __ ] pro war
community that exists and that's what
I'm pissed about is that somebody like
Tulsi Gabbard is being buried by the
media and by the [ __ ] corporatist
Democrat party that took over for the
progressives who I think actually care
about getting [ __ ] done for the people
and this is not me and Steve I this is
the [ __ ] that I can't believe has
happened right is that the progressives
have gotten [ __ ] over by this
corporatist wing of the Democrat Party
who uses Russia as a reason to kill all
arguments and and that's why we should
not investigate anything and so a mess
in this Trump impeachment [ __ ] is the
same thing it's optics to make all of
the Democrats corporatists and
progressives
feel good oh we got Trump but we didn't
he if anything we probably just gave him
a bunch of donors if anything we
probably just gave him a bunch of new
voters and that's what people don't
[ __ ] know that's the between the line
[ __ ] that happens if you read these
articles it's always like the
seventeenth paragraph is like Muller
found no collusion with Russia Muller
found nothing ma Lloyd used the Office
of Legal Counsel guidelines but then he
recanted like that's what people don't
understand and that's why when TIFF asks
me every time I see something about
Muller and like oh with the Russian
investigation never release anything
well guess what because it's all fever
it's all being played out before before
us all to just soak it up and open our
mouths new day
yes I love all this [ __ ] and real quick
before we and I know I've talked the
whole time sorry this is just Aman it's
awesome I love you guys we don't know
[ __ ] about okay point being when Mitch
McConnell the other day yesterday which
for mostly I don't know when this is
coming up but Collins ice cream Mitch
McConnell he's the he's the Republican
leader the Senate okay Mitch McConnell
came out and he said like all written
teach minutes all [ __ ] whatever okay
but what did Mitch McConnell say after
that that's what's more most interesting
about this stuff he talked about how the
Democrats who have spent weeks now in
months saying that Trump is a [ __ ]
Russian asset he's and he's a clear and
present danger right whatever I think
he's [ __ ] controlled so so they're
like he's a clear presentation all this
[ __ ] wanted mitchell can't talk about
talk about how we got we gave him a a
bunch of [ __ ] billions of dollars
like billions and billions of billions
of dollars for the military
so in trump was the commander in chief
of the military so why are they doing
that if he's a Russian asset or if he's
a [ __ ] traitor or if he's working for
the enemy it's all just a [ __ ] sy up
to make us all pissed about [ __ ] well we
all have to overpay for health care
overpay for education your college loans
are [ __ ] and [ __ ] you by the way
because that's what our government says
they say we're on do [ __ ] about any of
the stuff that matters we're just doing
fear for all the [ __ ] tools out there
who think all this [ __ ] matters with
impeachment it's just a game right the
same way they vote to spy on us every
time eighty eight votes out of [ __ ]
100 in the Senate like it's all just a
big [ __ ] joke to just keep us all in
line pissed at the right things I'm a
Republican I'm scared the Democrats
gonna take my guns I'm a Democrat
I'm scared the republics don't take my
abortions none of that ever happens it's
all a [ __ ] scam while we go to wars
that never end and while we all overpay
for everything and we give the military
even more money every year for [ __ ]
whatever reason while people who need
money in the inner cities and [ __ ] get
[ __ ] forgotten about forever and this
cycle will continue because that's
politics in America Republicans already
knew Trump wouldn't get impeached and
sort of the Democrats they're all
working together [ __ ] them all
[Music]